hands up guys my name is Jenna and what
the weekly update number six just make
it so I'm hearing in Switzerland and I
just thought that I'd make this weekly
update pretty cool sir I'll be back in
about well actually by the time you see
that's already be back I don't have
internet here and magistrates want to
let you guys know what the plan is
because i am in germany for another six
weeks so i'm gonna be putting out a
video pretty much every day because i'll
schedule them I found a party I put a
few friends here who have access to
internet that isn't mobile so therefore
is unlimited and kind of free for me
anyway so I'm gonna basically back to
upload a bunch video schedule with other
day for other week so that you you will
eventually will essentially get up
probably one video a day for like the
next well hopefully six weeks but i'm
i'm on i want to do that chat program
the the miniseries I'll mind talk more
about that later but it essentially is
just going to be a chat program i'll
actually talk about a letter and fit in
this video but there's that all right
and are we scheduled as well and
obviously game programming so there
should be maybe one video maybe two
videos game programming a little video
chat programs on yeah so check out the
view
it's epic
alright so I'm in Montreux right now I
wasn't burned before and I'm just want
to quickly explain what there's a chat
program for that so what I meant by that
is I was talking to go about this on
Facebook Twitter but I've seen novel
befallen test before basically the deal
was a mini chat program is and it
wouldn't be like very complex but it's
actually like a mini skype kind of thing
with our voice obviously just messages
and so there'd be a server and then at
the unlimited clients so what within
reason so you be able to have like
multiple clients connection to a single
server and every time that basically you
say something in the chat line and in
the program it will broadcast to all the
other programs and they could be
anywhere in the world and just basically
a little program that allows you to
message anyone enhance the program as
well and everything goes just through a
central server so that will be using UDP
protocol and some of that so that's what
the chat program told me about I don't
know how many episodes going to be but
it's probably gonna be like under 20
we'll see but yeah I mean this is
Montrose one so let's take a look at the
view
love those mountains
alright so I'm here interlachen now
still Swiss one obviously and I'm
strapping up its weekly up there so I
thought that I would let you know about
a little fun fact so I said in the hotel
here for two nights in a little village
that's got like four thousand people and
that and the village is called about and
hotel called prone and in that hopefully
that very same hotel I stayed in room
number 216 which is actually the last
room in the hotel and Bill Wyman who's
the lead guitarist for the Rolling
Stones he stayed there for two nights in
2010 in that same room in the same hotel
odds are three nights I think he said is
that therefore I in two thousand down so
that's where it's pretty awesome those
guys are also pretty awesome so hope you
guys enjoyed this weekly update this
Swiss weekly update and those Alps bro
there's Alps are amazing and yeah I mean
there's a lot of videos to come when we
get the exposure right there's a lot of
videos to come in the future so I hope
you guys will sort of that and yeah if
you enjoyed this Swiss quickly update
please leave a like and I'll see you
guys summertime goodbye